here in Park City Utah his client list
spans from Don Imus to Lenny Bruce and
art and Garbus is featured in a new
documentary shouting fire stories from
the edge of free speech the film screens
at Sundance and is directed by garbages
daughter Liz Garbus these do you think
threats from free speech are coming more
from the left or the right I think they
basically came more from the right I
think that what's gonna happen in the
future with the Obama administration
will be interesting the extent to which
the Obama administration keeps up some
of the regulations from the past about
restrictions on free speech and the
things like the military commissions Act
and other laws like that so I think
basically it comes from the right are
you worried which you see on college
campuses speech cards well I think
people like David Horowitz who are very
much involved on college campuses David
Horowitz he was published before the 100
worst college professors is a guy who
articulates the speech codes is there's
a lot of time with state legislators
trying to take control of the
universities away from what he sees it
as the liberal media and the film deals
with that it deals with the infestation
of well below the radar of the right in
trying to quell certain kinds of
discussions on campus whether it be
discussions about the Middle East or
discussions that are critical of Iraq
and
what do you think we can expect from the
Obama administration on free speech
issues well I'm not quite clear because
I think that the Obama administration
while having a proclivity to free speech
I'm not so sure how it plays out when
you had John Kennedy come in you had the
best and the brightest then you have the
Vietnam War and you have extraordinary
precedents peace free speech you now
have the best of the brightest coming in
again now I don't know what's gonna
happen politically over the next four to
eight years but the best and brightest
don't always that the best way with
respect to free speech so looking back
from four years from now is anyone's
guess I'm bomb is coming in with an 89%
positive rating break into the same two
years later they got banged in the
Reagan and perhaps Obama got banged in
the congressional elections so you're
looking at a very very small window why
are you I mean so many people are so ma
why why the skepticism
well I think that one should always be
skeptical in the government is always
you know you had the government of Jack
Kennedy and and one was always hopeful
then and they were horrendous when it
came to Vietnam the Bay of Pigs Lyndon
Johnson kept the same so you can look at
the best and the brightest back in the
Kennedy days where you can look perhaps
with the worst and the stupidest the
Bush days but the differences which
people led us into they weren't so
stupid they know where the oil was and
the Kennedy people were awfully stupid
they didn't know that much about
Southeast Asia so the mere fact that you
have a good government coming in doesn't
if you had to single out one of the
biggest the biggest violation of free
speech that's been perpetrated I think
you'd have to be the surveillance the
the ability to overhear anybody the
ability to wiretap it with under the
name
Terry gardening's Gartner with your
father